Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Savez-vous comment fonctionne
le cycle de l’eau ?
Vous vous souvenez de ce schéma
qu’on a tous appris à l’école,
où l’eau fait une boucle, des océans
aux continents en circuit fermé,
tranquillement, sans encombre ?
Eh bien, en fait, c'est faux.
C’est le résultat
d’une étude internationale
qui montre que quand on se représente
le cycle de l’eau,
on ne représente ni la pollution,
ni le changement climatique.
Or, c’est la toute première fois
depuis l’histoire de la Terre,
vieille de 4,5 milliards d’années,
qu’une seule espèce vivante
exerce une telle influence
sur le grand cycle de l’eau,
à tel point que nous en avons
franchi une limite planétaire,
celle de l’eau verte.
L’eau verte, c’est toute l’eau de pluie
qui s’infiltre dans les sols
et dont les plantes se servent
pour grandir.
On mesure cette eau verte
avec l’humidité des sols.
Avant l’anthropocène, l’humidité fluctuait
naturellement au fil des saisons.
Mais depuis l’extraction et la combustion
massive d’énergies fossiles,
gaz, charbon, pétrole,
on a complètement modifié
cette humidité des sols.
On voit de plus en plus d’événements
climatiques extrêmes, plus de canicules,
en plein dedans,
plus de sécheresses,
plus de pluies intenses.
Trop d’eau d’un coup,
plus d’eau pendant longtemps.
Sous l’eau ou à sec.
Toutes les régions du monde
sont concernées.
Alors, on a perturbé le climat,
ça c’est une chose,
mais on a aggravé le problème,
puisqu’on a continué à étaler nos villes,
à construire des routes,
à déforester massivement,
y compris en France où on cultive
du bois en appelant ça : forêt.
Et pour manger toujours plus de viande,
on casse des prairies naturelles
capables d’infiltrer l’eau de pluie
pour les remplacer par des monocultures
de céréales arrosées de pesticides
qui pompent toute l’eau des nappes.
Bref, on a complètement anéanti
la vie dans nos sols.
Nos sols sont morts.
Et des sols morts,
eh bien, ils ne peuvent tout simplement
plus infiltrer l’eau de pluie.
Pour résumer, on a des pluies
de plus en plus intenses
avec le changement climatique
et d’un autre côté des sols
de moins en moins capables d’infiltrer.
Résultat : la goutte qui tombe va
ruisseler et partir trop vite à la mer.
Pour comprendre cela, je vais vous
raconter l'histoire de deux gouttes d'eau
qui se livrent de nos jours
un véritable parcours du combattant.
Déjà, dès le départ, dans l’atmosphère,
nos gouttes d’eau vont se former
autour de polluants atmosphériques
émis par nos transports et nos industries.
Donc, dès le départ, la pluie est polluée.
Une goutte d’eau qu’on appellera Tchaka,
va tomber à la surface d’un sol agricole.
Un sol trop dur, trop sec, sans vie.
Vous l’aurez compris, Tchaka ne va pas
pouvoir s’infiltrer dans ce sol.
Elle va donc ruisseler et emporter
avec elle de nombreux polluants,
comme des pesticides ou des nitrates.
Elle va arriver dans une rivière
et la dévaler très rapidement
pour retrouver sa sœur Igota.
Igota lui raconte qu’elle aussi
elle a ruisselé très vite,
mais elle, à la surface d’un nouveau
parking qui vient d’être construit.
Les eaux sont troubles,
chargées en polluants.
Elles ont à peine le temps
de se reconnaître,
à peine le temps de se dire au revoir,
qu’elles se séparent.
Igota va continuer sa course folle
jusqu’à la mer
et emporter avec elle
tout un lot de polluants,
de mégots de cigarettes, et des
micropolluants comme des antibiotiques,
des hydrocarbures, des métaux
lourds, des pesticides.
En quelques jours, elle file tout droit
à la mer, beaucoup trop vite.
Tchaka, elle, va être aspirée
par un tuyau.
Elle va être malmenée dans
des kilomètres de canalisations.
Un jour, elle va finir dans
les chasses d’eau d’une toilette,
le lendemain, être traitée
par une station d’épuration
qui va la rejeter dans le fleuve.
Et à peine le temps de respirer
qu’elle va se retrouver
à refroidir une centrale nucléaire.
La centrale, elle fait le tri,
elle est en circuit fermé, donc la moitié
repart dans l’atmosphère
dans ces tours réfrigérantes
et l’autre moitié va repartir
dans le fleuve, mais plus chaude.
Tchaka, elle, elle veut retrouver
sa sœur, Igota, à la mer,
donc elle ne va pas s’évaporer
tout de suite.
Elle va repartir par le fleuve,
mais avec deux degrés de plus.
Fatiguée, elle va chercher à s’infiltrer
dans une nappe phréatique
et espérer s’y reposer quelque temps.
Sauf que dans cette grande
plaine agricole,
il y a de nombreux puits
qui puisent dans cette nappe
et certains vont remplir
d’immenses retenues noires.
Elle qui pensait se reposer
dans un aquifère bien au frais,
à l’abri de la chaleur et des polluants,
là, elle va se retrouver à croupir ici
pendant des jours, des semaines, des mois,
et comme beaucoup d’autres, elle sera
tentée de s’évaporer dans l’atmosphère.
Beaucoup vont le faire, mais elle non.
Elle, elle a la foi, elle y croit.
Elle va rester dans cette retenue, en
espérant pouvoir retourner dans le fleuve,
quitte à se laisser envahir
par des algues.
Un jour, au milieu de l’été,
elle est aspirée et propulsée
dans un air caniculaire.
Il fait 40 degrés à l’ombre, il est midi.
Toutes les rivières alentour souffrent.
Elle aura à peine le temps
d’atteindre un épi de maïs
qu’elle n’aura pas d’autre choix
que de s’évaporer.
Fin de la partie.
Dans cette histoire, Tchaka ne pourra pas
retourner dans le fleuve
dans lequel elle a été prélevée.
Elle ne pourra pas soutenir toute
la vie aquatique qui en a besoin.
Elle ne retournera pas à la mer
retrouver sa sœur Igota.
Elle va repartir dans les courants
atmosphériques
et se précipiter bien plus loin
dans un autre pays.
Ça, c’était l’histoire
de deux gouttes d’eau
qui luttent pour ne pas être accaparées
par nos activités humaines.
Car chaque année, l’humanité s’approprie
24 000 milliards de mètres cube d’eau,
c’est l’équivalent de la moitié
de tous les débits des fleuves
qui s’écoulent aux océans de la planète.
Et c’est toute l’eau qu’on s’approprie
pour fabriquer notre alimentation,
nos vêtements,
nos objets du quotidien, etc.
Ces 24 000 milliards
de mètres cubes d’eau,
c’est l’empreinte eau annuelle
de l’humanité.
C’est toute l’eau de pluie et toute l’eau
contenue dans les sols,
l’eau contenue dans les cours d’eau,
dans les nappes,
que l’on mobilise pour fabriquer
notre alimentation.
C’est aussi l’eau nécessaire à fabriquer
notre énergie pour nous chauffer,
pour communiquer, nous déplacer,
pour fabriquer des objets ici
qui seront consommés ailleurs.
Cette histoire, je la connais trop,
je l’ai trop entendue, je l’ai trop vue.
Je l’ai même ressentie en constatant
l’état de nos rivières.
En fait, il existe une autre version
de cette histoire,
bien plus réjouissante.
Allez, je vous emmène
dans un autre espace-temps
pour parcourir un cycle
de l’eau régénérée.
Dans cet espace-temps, admettons,
c’est très simple dit comme ça,
que l’humanité a réussi
à résoudre le casse-tête climatique
en tenant ses engagements.
Même si l’atmosphère continue
à se réchauffer,
même si le niveau marin
continue à augmenter,
les Terriens ont réussi
à régénérer le cycle de l’eau.
Déjà, au départ, les micro-gouttelettes
ne vont pas se former autour de polluants,
mais autour de spores de champignons,
de poussières et de bactéries.
C’est un véritable cortège
de particules biologiques
que l’on retrouve naturellement
au-dessus des canopées forestières.
Au-dessus de ces forêts,
on retrouve ces rivières volantes,
des nuages qui voguent
sur la cime des arbres.
En fait, la régénération des cycles
de l’eau repose sur ce constat :
plus un paysage est habité par des forêts
peu modifiées par l’homme,
plus ce paysage sera capable de retenir
et de recycler l’eau de pluie.
En fait, les arbres interceptent
l’eau de pluie,
la puisent dans les sols
en la faisant remonter par capillarité
et ils l’évapotranspirent.
Par exemple, savez-vous
qu’un arbre mature, un chêne,
est capable d’évaporer
jusqu’à 1000 litres d’eau par jour ?
Mais toute cette eau n’est pas perdue :
souvenez-vous, il y a cet ensemble
de particules biologiques
qui va permettre de reprécipiter la pluie
au-dessus de cette même forêt,
ou bien un petit peu plus loin,
au-dessus d’une autre canopée.
Les arbres sont plus puissants
que n’importe quelle technologie.
Ils le font depuis des millions,
des centaines de millions d’années.
Retour en France avec Tchaka et Igota
qui cette fois vont précipiter
à la surface d’une forêt comestible
cultivée par une coopérative agricole.
On y voit des champs de pâturage
peuplés d'arbres fruitiers.
On y voit des petites parcelles
de vignes ou de céréales
cultivées entre deux rangées d’arbres.
Tchaka et Igota vont tomber à la surface
de cette canopée forestière.
Igota va repartir aussitôt
dans l’atmosphère,
mais Tchaka va rester sur cette ferme.
Elle va parcourir un long circuit
conçu de manière à la ralentir,
à l’aider à s’infiltrer dans les sols.
Elle va passer par ces baissières.
Ce sont des petites cuvettes végétalisées
construites perpendiculairement
aux pentes et qui suivent des courbes
de niveau entre deux rangées d’arbres.
Et là, elle va s’infiltrer
lentement dans le sol.
Elle va parcourir un paysage aquatique
peuplé de centaines d’espèces
d’amphibiens, d’insectes, d’oiseaux,
qui se nourrissent d’autres espèces,
ce qui limite la propagation de ravageurs,
ou de maladies préjudiciables
aux cultures.
Elle va s’infiltrer lentement,
puis rejoindre une rivière exempte
de pesticides, exempte de nitrates.
Après un violent orage,
la rivière va sortir de son lit.
Dans cette grande plaine, les hommes
ont choisi de sanctuariser,
de ne plus rien construire ici,
voire d’abaisser les digues
pour laisser de la place à la rivière,
pour qu’elle divague de droite à gauche.
Elle va reprendre ses droits,
repeupler des zones humides,
reconquérir des bras morts
et se reconnecter à sa nappe.
Tchaka va donc pouvoir s’infiltrer
dans cette nappe,
et passer devant un tuyau
qui ne la pompe pas,
car les hommes ont choisi de laisser
cette nappe tranquille.
Plus loin, elle va ressortir dans
cette rivière qui va traverser une ville.
Autrefois, cette rivière était canalisée,
enterrée à l’abri des regards
et chargée de polluants.
Là, les hommes ont choisi de la découvrir,
d’adoucir ses pentes
et de végétaliser avec des saules et des
peupliers qui donnent de l’ombre en été.
Ils donnent de l’ombre et aussi des abris
pour certaines espèces aquatiques,
comme des poissons migrateurs
qui étaient autrefois menacés d’extinction
car ils étaient bloqués
en contrebas par des obstacles.
Là, les hommes ont choisi
d’effacer certains seuils,
de construire des rampes à poissons
sur certains barrages
et très vite,
les petits insectes d’eau douce,
des invertébrés qui sont à la base
de la chaîne trophique,
mais aussi ces poissons migrateurs,
sont venus repeupler la rivière
et se reproduire à l’exact
endroit où ils sont nés.
Tchaka va retrouver sa sœur Igota,
qui provient d’un jardin de pluie.
Ce sont des petites cuvettes végétalisées
construites au milieu des villes.
Peut-être en avez-vous déjà vu.
Elles permettent de recueillir
toute cette eau
qui ruisselle sur la chaussée
et sur les toitures.
Et elle va l'infiltrer tout doucement.
Ensemble, elles vont vivre
une incroyable épopée.
Tantôt, elles vont être ralenties
par une zone humide,
recyclées par une forêt,
ralenties par un barrage de castors
et s’endormir dans une nappe.
Elles vont parcourir tout le bassin
versant d’amont en aval
et rencontrer de nombreuses
cousines qui, comme elles,
ont plein d’histoires à raconter.
Et finalement, elles vont rejoindre
leur dernier exutoire : la mer.
Elle la rejoignent, non plus chargées
de polluants, mais chargées d’histoires.
Elles ont accompli leur cycle de l’eau
et portent en elles les empreintes de
nombreuses vies passées sur le continent.
Si vous avez été touchés par
l’histoire de ces deux gouttes d’eau
et que la deuxième, celle du cycle
de l’eau régénérée, vous a plu,
alors je vous invite à prêter attention
à ce qui dépend de vous.
Il s'agit de votre empreinte eau.
Vous vous souvenez de l’empreinte eau ?
Eh bien, en fait,
on peut la calculer par pays.
On sait que pour chaque
Français, en moyenne,
l’empreinte eau quotidienne se situe
entre 5000 et 7000 litres d’eau par jour.
5000 litres d’eau invisible par jour,
c’est l’équivalent de 25 baignoires
que l’on remplit d’eau virtuelle
pour fabriquer votre alimentation,
vos vêtements, vos objets du quotidien.
Par exemple, un kilo de bœuf, 15 000
litres d’eau, un avocat, 500 litres d’eau,
un jean, 11 000 litres d’eau,
un smartphone, 12 000 litres d’eau.
Mais en fait, quand on regarde
de plus près, dans ces 5000 litres,
85 % sont directement liés
à notre alimentation.
En clair, nous mangeons de l’eau
et il s’agit essentiellement
de l’eau verte.
Nous mangeons de l’eau
en lien avec notre régime carné.
Donc la bonne nouvelle, c'est que chacun
d'entre nous peut faire quelque chose.
On peut végétaliser notre assiette
en mangeant moins de viande,
plus de légumes et de légumineuses
et acheter des produits
issus d’une agriculture paysanne
locale, de proximité,
qui va respecter les saisons,
et aussi prendre soin des sols,
des arbres, de la biodiversité, de l’eau.
En faisant ça, vous avez l’immense pouvoir
de préserver l’eau verte
contenue dans les sols
et préserver l’eau bleue contenue
dans les cours d’eau et dans les nappes,
que ce soit chez vous ou ailleurs.
Parce que c’est ça, l’histoire
d’un cycle de l’eau régénérée.
C’est partager un bien commun.
C’est considérer les hommes
non plus au-dessus
mais faisant partie
d’un grand cycle de l’eau.
L’autre bonne nouvelle, c’est que,
en fait, pour régénérer
les cycles de l’eau,
tout le monde peut comprendre
cette histoire,
aussi bien les agriculteurs que les élus,
que les citoyennes, les citoyens,
comme vous et moi.
Tout le monde mange, donc tout
le monde peut faire quelque chose.
L’hydrologie régénérative,
cette science qui va régénérer
les cycles de l’eau,
elle s’invite absolument partout,
dans votre potager,
sur le terrain d’un agriculteur,
autour d’une rivière et même en ville,
en montagne, en plaine,
sur le littoral, partout,
on peut régénérer ce cycle de l’eau.
Pour que cette histoire devienne réalité,
elle doit s’immiscer
dans notre conscience,
elle doit s’inviter dans notre société.
Par le choix de notre alimentation,
mais aussi dans notre manière
d’être au monde.
Donc finalement,
si on veut régénérer l’eau,
on va faire comme ces deux petites
gouttes d’eau, Tchaka et Igota.
En un mot, on va ralentir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)